and this is a cosmic queries Edition on
science in pop fiction
what does that mean
I got my resident geek in Chief with me
Charles Lou Charles welcome back to
start talk what up you're like such a
regular on this show I live to serve
thank you for having me there he goes
and Chuck nice that's right as always
dude that's right always a pleasure to
be here man all right so you got we
solicited questions in pop fiction so
Chuck what do you have on shows like the
Oroville and many others they often
communicate with people light years away
they never explain how they do it maybe
there's a wire that passes through a
tiny Wormhole to connect Earth uh what
I'm wondering though is if they were
able to reliably share the same sense of
time for the duration of their
conversation with one of them sound like
a chipmunk and the other sound like
they're in slow motion what other weird
effects might occur that's a great a
really great question because you know
we're so distracted by oh that wouldn't
make noise in the vacuum of space right
this person's thinking deep yes see it
about conversations we have this issue
with communicating with the Mars rover
right the Mars rover what's the delay on
the Mars on average about 20 minutes so
is it so yeah hello watch out for the
cliff and it's too late so you got to
make sure for myself for the cliff
that's why the Rovers all have some kind
of AI on them to know where they're
headed and and how dangerous it might be
right regardless of what command we give
them it's like having a lousy parent at
the playground you know what I mean
so say so clearly they're communicating
with people much farther away than just
Earth to Mars right so I'm thinking it's
got to be some Wormhole uh channel uh
Charles you got an opinion about that in
Star Trek specifically there is this
construct called Subspace yeah which
transcends a regular space and time and
basically anything that happens in
Subspace you can just assume works just
as if you and I were next door to each
other or in the same room in real time
yes but that completely doesn't affect
the entire rest of space and time it's
really uh it's very false entertaining
convenient construct it'd be cool if
that were the thing right right it would
so Verizon FiOS eat your heart out right
okay so the comments about whether or
not you sound like a chipmunk or you
talk really slowly
so that kind of uh effect is what we
call the Doppler effect right especially
the Doppler effect for sound and kneel
you and I understand that very well uh
just when we're out on the streets in
New York and the ambulance goes by or
something like that well they go back
too slowly to have any Doppler effect at
all yeah well in New York they do yeah
in Russia every time I see an ambulance
in New York I'm like that guy's dead
I'm just saying
it's like sitting at a light for 20
minutes
have you ever watched a superhero sci-fi
movie that hadn't made you cringe and if
so what was it I think that let's frame
that positively is there a superhero or
sci-fi movie that you have watched and
appreciated the amount of science that
was built in and the uh the level of
science accuracy let's trade off you're
okay give me a movie and I'll give you a
movie and we'll just and we'll go down
the list maybe we can do like how long
did it take before I started to cringe
or something like that okay the movie
that made me cringe least it was
interesting the 1966 Batman movie
where they all became
head back
and they're identical to each other
except they're speaking each other's
languages that's right which by the way
is almost as believable as the Tower of
Babel so the reason it wasn't
cringe-worthy for me is because I knew
that it was totally chemistry to begin
with so in that vein right my movie
where I just said okay I am leaving all
reality reality no matter what we're
spending all this Attack of the Killer
Tomatoes yes
all right okay okay so the tomatoes just
jumping and smothering people and I said
okay
but my only regret is I still don't know
if you're a fruit or a vegetable
for current Universe superhero things
the thing the least cringe-worthy
superhero movie that I've actually seen
is
Doctor Strange doctor strange and the
reason that doesn't cringe me the
premise of the movie is that none of
this is science anyway or as say right
as Reed Richards would say on his you
know that Fantastic Four comic series he
he regularly would say I acknowledge
that science uh that magic is a science
I do not yet understand he did say that
that's right yes and so as a result so
did Princess Bubblegum by the way I
don't mean to boast okay you can line up
for autographs later okay but I have a
cameo in Sharknado 6. out of their way
there's a Sharknado coming the plot line
takes you back to Medieval Times uh I
play Merlin there's a Time Warp that
opens in the vortex of course there is
okay I mean when the Sharks as they go
through the vortex they end up cross
breeding in this Vortex with dragons and
so you have shark Dragon tornadoes back
then okay Shark Dragon NATO's and I play
Merlin performing actual science that
everyone thinks is Magic because because
you're still a scientist because I'm a
scientist and that was I was true to my
my roots now you do realize that you can
say no to these projects
hey Chuck will it one day be possible
for entire societies to disguise
themselves in plain sight as wakanda did
in the Marvel Universe how close are we
to developing invisibility technology so
let's get the top presentations of that
so you have the cloaking device on Stark
Trek yeah and also one of the James Bond
movies I forgot which one it was called
but it has something called adaptive
camouflage so you could park it and
whatever it was in front of it would
bring that pattern to the car and you'd
walk by it and you just thought you were
looking at a normal scene right so
there's that there was also cloaking in
chicken little
okay excuse me is my cinematic
repertoire too large for you that
probably sucks anytime you're reference
okay the sky is falling was not a real
Sky they were hexagonal tiles that the
aliens had put over the earth and the
tile is an exact image of what is behind
it right and when a tile fell down it
fell to the ground
and Chicken Little looked at it and
touched it and it immediately became the
floorboards and he put it on a table it
became the table and so this five
minutes of this movie doing experiments
with the hexagonal tile so basically
it's cloaking by not becoming invisible
but by becoming what is behind flaws but
camouflage the cloak and Harry the cloak
and Harry Potter you have the Invisible
Woman uh Fantastic Four character right
right you can turn invisible right and
then you have the entire city being
closed right yes so can we cloak an
entire city well in wakanda yeah they
did that um the answer at the moment is
no
at the moment the answer is that we can
seem to be able to bend light around
objects in such a way that the object
would not be visible to someone looking
at it because all they'd see is the
background and you don't even know the
light is bending you just see the
direction the light comes from at the
last point of contact so the light can
do a full
three six four three six hundred eighty
doesn't matter right and you look at if
all the light
coherently comes around the object right
again you've rendered it um invisible
that is at this moment only doable in
the laboratory under very extreme
conditions and sort of at the subatomic
level okay however Charles but I thought
I thought I thought DARPA was working on
a cloak like that's the kind is that it
is that what okay I'm not authorized to
speak any program so but but here's a
problem the city is sitting on the
ground yes you can't bring light from
behind the city around it
right so it so that technology wouldn't
work to hide a city right it would only
hide objects in front of other things
well in this wakanda they had it was a
dome that covered the city as well right
there was some kind of like forced Dome
that then cloaked the city right the
dome in that case was really just almost
a mirror in a sense it projected upon
itself oh pastoral images of goat
herders okay so it didn't disappear it's
just it's just it's projection screen
it's just a projection screen and then
you had to get through it and then you
saw all the marvelous Technologies
that's right cool that that we can do
where are we projecting movies onto
skyscrapers aren't we you don't got me
about wakanda how is it that down in the
town this is with all this technology
and all this I all this stuff they're
still selling woven baskets
in the street what's up with that I
believe it's very simple what because
they realize they essentially have
infinite wealth and infinite technology
yeah what makes them happy it's not the
toy baskets that's baskets what
superpower would you like to have that
could be theoretically enabled by Gene
editing oh Charles you go first
I would say and I know this might seem a
little goofy but with Gene editing the
best thing that I could hope for for
myself is that my genes make it so that
I will stay as mentally and physically
in perfect health as long as I want
Charles no one is making a movie about
that maybe not all right Niels what was
yours be so Charles is going to live
forever I've thought about this actually
so what I would do is I'd say give me
genes that a snake has where I can open
my mouth five times bigger than my head
so I can finally eat suck the sandwich
at the deli
pastrami sandwich at the deli okay but
that's not a superpower that's just that
I want to throw that in there okay okay
um snakes can detect in in infrared okay
okay insects can see deeply in the
ultraviolet right which is why bug
zappers work because they're ultraviolet
and they said I gotta go to the
ultraviolet and then they die so I want
to be able to see infrared see
ultraviolet also
I want to be able to Gene edit other
people
so that
I can help regenerate the limbs
of veterans who lost limbs defending
this country cool and newts can
regenerate exactly humans can't it is in
the Genome of the Tree of Life to
regenerate Limbs and so I want to be
able to have that to then impart that in
fellow humans and so that everybody gets
their limbs back that's the kind of
thing well I'm going with super strength
and sproutling wings like a beetle so
that I don't have wings all the time
because you know that probably get on my
nerves when I'm trying to sleep well so
you want wings that tuck in under an
extra scale under an exoskeleton pop out
when I want to fly and then super
strength and by the way I'm not helping
anybody I'm going on a life of crime uh
so you'll be a super villain I'd be a
super villain without a doubt and then
you guys could figure out a way to stop
me
thank you
[Music]